الاقتصاد شريان اساسي للاستمرار في اي حرب
تندلع تماما كما قررت روسيا ان تلجا
الاقتصاد الحرب بعد ما ايقنت ان الصراع
سيطول امده وفي هذه الحاله تسخر الدوله في
هذه الظروف الاستثنائيه اقتصادها لضمان
كسب المعركه باتخاذ اجراءات الطوارئ عبر
اعتماد نظام الانتجي يعمل على توفير
الموارد الاقتصاديه من اجل استمراريه
التماسك على المستوى الداخلي المدني وكسب
المواجهه العسكريه
وتنتظر روسيا حزمه عقوبات عاشره من دول
الغرب واوروبا كان اخرها وضع سقف للاورال
الروسيه عندها 60 دولارا للبرميل الواحد
حينها وصف الرئيس فلاديمير بوتن قرارات
التثقيف لانها غبيه واوضاع الحكومه
الماليه الصامده لا محاله مره شهر والجميع
يت تواعك موسكو في اقتصادها فهو مفتاح
الامداد عسكريا لقواتها على ارض اوكرانيا
وبين ما تجتمع 100 وثلاثون دوله في الحدث
الاقتصادي السنوي في دافوس قرر بوتن ان
يرسم صوره ورديه لاقتصاديه بلادته وقال ان
الدينميكيات الفعليه للاقتصاد قد جاءت
افضل مما يتوقع الكثير من الخبراء واكد ان
الانكماش الذي جرى في الاقتصاد الروسي
افضل من التراجع الذي سجلته اوكرانيا وجاء
بنسبه 33%
انخفض الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لروسيا في
الفتره من يناير الى نوفمبر عام 2022 ولكن
بالنسبه اثنين فاصل واحد في المئه فقط
بينما توقع خبراؤنا في البلاد ولا اتحدث
عن الاجانب توقعوا انخفاضا بنسبه 10:15
ولو حتى 20% عموما من المتوقع ان يكون
الانخفاض السنوي اثنين فاصله 5%
لضغط على روسيا اقتصاديا خاصه على نفطها
لانه المصدر الرئيسي
لثروه وبالتاكيد المدخل الاساسي للحرب
تقول صحيفه نيوز بيك الامريكيه ان كاف وضع
علمها يجب ان يتاكد من ان موسكو لم يعد
لديها ما يكفي من النقود وعلى الغربه ان
يضغط عليهم بالعقوبه اكثر لان ما اشار
اليه بوتن حول الميزانيه فهو براي علاج
اوستنكو المستشعر الاقتصادي للرئيس بولودي
ميرزلينسكي مخادع فالسوق لا يقول ذلك
فحسب تقرير المركز الفنلندي المستقلي
ابحاث الطاقه والهواء النظيف الحد الاقصى
البالغ 60 دولار للبرميل يقضي على ارباح
موسكو المربحه من النفط ويكلف الكريم من
حوالي
172 مليون دولار يوميا مضيفا ان روسيا
ثالث اكبر منتج للنف في العالم تبيعوا
بعضا من خام الاورال الرئيسي لديها باقل
من 60 دولاره بكثير للبرميل على سبيل
المثال الى الهند وقال استنجو انهم
يراوغون الحقيقه لانه مستعدون لبيع نفقهم
حتى باسعار منخفضه والاجراءات المتعلقه
بصادرات النفط الروسيه هي اقوى الادوات
الرائعه ووافقه بلومبرج فانا عاوزه
الميزانيه الشهريه لروسيا بلغ مستوى
قياسيا 56 مليار دولار في ديسمبر من عام
200 و20 وهو ما رفع العجز السنوي في
البلاد الى حوالي 48 مليار دولار يعتقد
خبراء طاقه ان 2023 سيكون عام الحسم بنسبه
لتاثيره هذه العقوبات التي فرضها الغرب
على النفط والغاز الروسيين
[موسيقى]
فقط
بحاجه لسرعه القرارات العالم تردد عام
2014 حين احتلت روسيا القرن والعالم تردد
حين بدات الحرب الحاليه ولذلك يجب ان
الاحترام ضد العالم الان روسيا تصدر
الارهاب وتهدده بنشر الحرب الى العالم
واخرانيه تقدموا معادله السلام كما يجب ان
نتحرك بشكل اسرع من العدو الروسي ويجب ان
يكون تقديم المساعدات العسكريه اسرع من
هجمات روسيا على اوكرانيا